the Joe Rogan experience what do you
think is responsible for that shift from
Ted of 2008 to Ted of 2019 Michael
Pollan's book probably yeah Michael
Pollan's book was was the big bridge no
he has 40 pages on me and Michael if
you're listening buddy dude I told him
not to reveal my secret mushroom touch
never trust a journalist and Michael
Pollan bless his heart I love him he's a
great guy but he said in his book so so
to speak he says Paul told me not to
tell you where my his secret mushroom
patch is but I can tell you that we
slept in a yurt there are three state
parks along the Columbia River and two
of them have yurts you just basically
gave up your spot my spot and it's like
okay Michael well do that I think it's
the urge of the writer trying to give
something to their readership you know
so what happened to that spot get raised
it's it's run over with people
collecting so side mushrooms they have
big signs everywhere they rush people
it's a huge income source now the tops
for the cops because they bust people
but it but the good news about that as I
have gone on three state parks and
because there's big signs of no mushroom
picking a law enforcement there there's
lots of mushrooms they're everywhere and
so I can photograph them but you're not
allowed to touch them so they look what
do they check you on your way out oh
there there are like bees on honey so to
speak come on
they are hiding in the bushes there are
alpha males in that they're difficult
and they start it they strode touches I
had a lot of fun with my friend because
I got a stick and I go okay I touched
the mushrooms with a stick now am I
actually touching the mushrooms or not
because if you touch them they check
your pockets they will search you yeah
they'll search you for just randomly no
if they have reason to believe reason to
believe they can search you stuff them
in your underwear bro just take a big
fat baggie or swallow them quickly but
um
you know I don't this is
it is preposterous well if they find you
lying down with your eyes dilated you'd
have to talk to them you know I don't
know if they would do a fecal sample
later on or what Christ but it is it
approaches the absurd
yeah you know and this is when the law
enforcement because it was absurd even
the law enforcement officers I know who
you know even the martial arts a lot all
your life myself as well I had several
schools for about thirty years and I had
several law enforcement officers or
students yeah they don't want to be
involved I know they get roped into it
by the system yeah they'd like this is
not something they want to do I know a
ton of cops or not none of them give a
[ __ ] about mushrooms yeah it's yeah it's
hugely hugely unfortunate consequence of
really ridiculous laws and in the idea
of grown adults telling other grown
adults that they can't do something that
is incredibly beneficial that they
themselves have never experienced they
have no knowledge of it at all other
than the ancient stereotypes mushrooms
being bad mushrooms being for burnouts
and losers and hippies and all you can't
handle life those are walking hypocrites
and they're tormented but they have to
do this so I found that most law
enforcement officers are extremely
reasonable yeah as long as you show
intent you know yeah respect respect
yeah so it's it's never been but you
know I don't subscribe to the defense
that someone joined for spiritual
purposes and they have you know hundreds
of pounds with ziplock bags with scales
in the basement and a commercial
operation right you're avoiding taxes
right you're producing this as a factory
you know take it in the chin you get
busted a comes with the territory
yeah eyes wide open don't cloak it in
like the in the veil of spirituality
you're trying to create a spiritual
revolution unless you're a true Saint
you're giving that [ __ ] away yeah well
that would be different but yeah I I
have a phrase nature provides I don't
because I don't want to be responsible
for another person's experience so for
sure what if they have a meltdown and
they blame Joe Rogan yes Paul stam yes I
don't I can't control
that circumstance I don't want the
responsibility mm-hmm it's one of the
reasons why I've hesitated on getting
involved in medical marijuana or so you
know commercial marijuana have been
offered and I'm always like how much
don't think this is a right because you
can't especially with edibles you can't
control people you don't know what
they're gonna do
[Applause]